hey everyone today we're doing a video
that answers a lot of questions that
we've been getting in comments uh you
might have seen the last few videos that
we released our performances
that Michael and I have done of some
Baroque repertoire and if you've heard
those pieces you've heard that Michael
sings very high using his falsetto but
when he speaks come here you speak hello
he speaks normally so why is this so we
thought let's do a little video and
explain to you what is a countertenor
yeah sure so a counter tenor is above
tenor a male that would sing above uh
the natural tenor sound would be and
what's the tenor maybe some people don't
know right a tenor is going to be the
highest of male voices other than a
countercenter but in speaking register
or in what we call modal voice so what
you're hearing right now chest voice
also right chest voice right exactly
really how I see it is that there are
three General parts of the voice that I
use
um technically throughout my rep and
that is my chest voice followed by what
I call a mix then an actual head Voice
or what a lot of people know as a
falsetto can we hear an example of each
one yeah so so a chest voice for example
would sound like as I speak or as I sing
in a higher pitch it would be
foreign
that idea and then like a mixed sound
would be as I get a little bit in
between those two voice types so to be
that idea oh and then as I get higher I
start to go into what's actual head
Voice or a falsetto so it sounds like
this
[Applause]
whoa
So within piecing all of that together
it is one voice it's not that I sing as
two different voices and I I really
don't necessarily see them as two
different voice types it's just an
extension of what I do when I was in
high school I joined this this group
called the Houston grand opera High
School voice studio and in my audition
for that group we had sight reading and
they played the tonic chord for for that
sight reading to help me hear my key
in this really high pitch and I was like
I guess they want me to sing up there so
I did and what ended up happening was my
teacher said have you ever thought about
singing countertender well and I asked
the same question that probably many of
you have asked what's that and so uh in
that audition I ended up changing my
life without even knowing it because I
started this Trek of learning about
early music and learning about what a
countertender is and who knows maybe
some of you could be a countertender
um
because we all have that ability to sing
in our falsetto and so I still sing
tenor and I still sing like if I sing
pop music I'll sing as a tenor but
really a lot of even pop singers we know
today are considered counter Tenors
um and so some of my favorites are like
Mitch Grassi who sings with Pentatonix
he's a natural male Alto but you also
have even people like Freddie Mercury
even like Frankie Valli from the Jersey
Boys
um all right what's the one the song for
that everybody knows from Jersey Boys
it's that idea like we've all used this
and it comes from from a really a long
line of history of people liking High
voices and so everything from like
Maroon 5 that we all know to even uh the
history of where where the countercenter
voice comes from which is the castrato
we're going to get into that we can yeah
there's a lot there's a lot to say about
that before we do I wanted to also
mention that like for example uh I used
to listen to a lot of 80s metal and
things right and that style a lot of
people first of all they're all super
high Tenors uh and then a lot of them
end up using their falsetto with even a
wide operatic vibrato I used to listen
to a lot of Iron Maiden right and he
uses that sound all the time
uh and uh Queen's Reich and all these
other they're incredibly versatile uh
singers and actually so for me I was
already familiar with that voice type
before I ever got into early music and
discovered but uh what a camera Tanner
was or even let alone what a
historically a castrato was uh so that's
probably one of the most shocking things
I think we got one funny comment on our
YouTube video which is like are you sure
he's not a castrato and so fill us in uh
what is a castrato um what are we
talking about right so castrato is uh
well it was they've outlawed this
practice thankfully uh thankfully
um but essentially what would happen in
17th 16th century Italy is that they
would have these really beautiful boy
choirs and they would attract these
awesome singers and they'd come in and
they would learn from such a young age
and when they found a voice that was
that was Exquisite they would then
castrate them and so that they could
keep that delicate high voice sound that
we all like and I and I think it came
from this practice of creating these
Superstar talents
um and preserving this Angelic sound
like if we we've all heard like a child
speak it's such a beautiful it's a cute
it's a really nice sound and say they
wanted to preserve that right before
their voice drops and they go through
that awkward cracking stage right and
eventually they can no longer sing it so
this is yeah this is a way of preserving
that beautiful boy soprano High register
right and so unfortunately these kids
got really famous like really like
really famous Justin Bieber amount of
Fame and um so they were truly the rock
stars of their day and so they would
castrate
thousands of children in order to to
preserve this sound but not all of them
ended up being famous I was gonna I was
gonna mention that that's kind of the
the saddest part I was thinking you know
that's terrible what they did to them
but then they went on to be super
celebrity rock stars but no I mean a
small percentage of them small
percentage right right only had part of
their lives ruined you know exactly and
and so those those not to diverge too
much but they would they would be stuck
in churches or in places of of work that
um that might not be great and not to
mention some of the the the uh surgeries
didn't go very well and so that's oh
yeah right we're dealing with like 17th
century medicine exactly but
thankfully
through that we got some of the most
Divine music in my opinion in the world
that's ever been written
[Music]
so today you're singing as a
countertenor in roles and operas that
were meant for castrati right yeah they
would have been written for they
actually in many of the scores have
written exactly who who would have been
the castrato so for example a very
famous castrato was named senesino and
so you'll see almost every famous role
that George Frederick Handel wrote for
an alto it was written for that same guy
well yeah I've only ever heard one
castrato because there's like there's
this famous recording you can watch on
YouTube I'll put it in the description
[Music]
which is known as kind of the last
Estrada you can listen to I hear he
might have been past this Prime and it
sounds a little a little weird to listen
to right but you can actually listen to
a recording around I don't know like
1900 wait basically Recording Technology
started to capture this and so you can
check that out yeah I think just to to
kind of finish the point of the castrato
into the counter tenor why we have such
a an important part and role in in our
new productions of broke operas because
these castrati would bring in this
masculinity and this kind of heroic
style uh characterizations and now we
have what was what is called Pants rolls
and so a lot of mezzo Sopranos or female
presenting characters will will come in
and they'll they'll sing castrato rules
um but this this new rise of
countertender allows for uh male
presenting people to come and sing these
roles and give a little bit more of the
the size and the masculinity that might
be more comparable to what a castrato
would have would have been well when a
male voice learns how to really develop
that falsetto register and craft it and
control it uh it can be a really
beautiful thing uh you know we all know
it maybe you do like a Mickey Mouse
impression you know this type of voice
up here is your falsetto but actually to
learn how to hone that and make it sound
as beautiful and controlled as Michael
can it's so sweet and light and
especially we were talking about it
earlier playing with just one plucking
loot or fiorbo and that voice is such a
beautiful pairing
[Music]
foreign
we all have this energy in this this
care and want to hear things that are
ethereal so so there's other voice types
that are also out of the ordinary like a
contralto and when I hear like a
contralto or a very low bass sound it's
just it's magnificent it's something
that you don't hear all the time and so
we get this kind of new or wow factor
about it and I think one thing that's
really important to me about that to get
across about counterintenders is that
it's just an extension of your normal
voice and that everybody can do it it
just takes years and time and practice
and uh care to to create something that
is really maybe not effortless because
it's not effortless but it is it is
definitely
um I think it's just a part of what I do
right let's hear an example now we want
to hear the whole piece but let's hear a
little example of some of the recordings
we made if you haven't yet heard them
[Music]
foreign studying
foreign
[Music]
voice is such a beautiful sound and
Michael's in particular I'm a huge fan
of your voice so thank you for for doing
all this if you are enjoying this and
you want to learn more about counter
Tenors or listen to some other famous
countertenders uh Michael who can they
listen to who would you recommend right
I think it's important to know that the
Resurgence of the countertender voice
within the classical realm didn't happen
all that long ago it was it was really
started with uh the composer Benjamin
Britton who wrote who started writing
for this counterintendent named Alfred
deller oh yeah and it's an interesting
sound Alfred is um but it was he's
really the the segue into what we now
know as the modern countertender
[Music]
I listened to a lot of alfredeller when
I was in college I discovered him and I
thought especially for that time I think
it was to hear that to have that type of
voice in the world right showing how
beautiful this music can be uh was
really important so I I loved listening
to I would strongly recommend yeah and I
would go from Alfred deller to uh James
Bowman and Russell Oberlin Arts three of
the the major uh beginnings of what we
now know as the counterintowner voice uh
within classical music and then as we
started to get later into the field
um my very favorite countertender is
Andreas Shull he's a German
counter-center
[Music]
gorgeous voice but some other guys that
are really taking care of this voice
part is Philippe jeruski and we have
David Daniels and then going forward
from there some Modern counter Tenors
that are singing today are John Holliday
there's a new sopranist his name is
kimon Mara that I've sung with
Jaco berlinski and yeah there's so many
counter centers out there to listen to
and what I love about the countercenter
voice is that every single person I've
sung with or I've met or I've listened
to is different I've really not heard
two counter tennis that sound exactly
the same it's true that's a good point
and I think that's so fascinating and
everybody has their own color and maybe
we'll hear one of you guys sing sing
with a different color so please do
check out all these examples of
wonderful singers that Michael mentioned
and of course our recordings that we've
made we have three videos now that we we
made that you can check out in the
description below so Michael this is a
real treat thank you so much for sharing
uh with with my YouTube audience and I
can't wait to do prepare with you soon
yeah it's my pleasure man thanks for
having me on thanks and we'll see you
guys next time foreign
[Music]